[Music]
tomorrow surfing makes its debut as an
olympic event it's one of the world's
oldest sports and as lucy kraft reports
it's been gaining in popularity in the
host nation of japan
they arrive lugging boards on foot or
on two wheels among the estimated
two million japanese who ride waves many
crowd in here
one of the most beloved surf spots in
the country
it's only a little after seven a.m but
we're well into rush hour down here at
kuganuma beach
some of these boards have been in the
water since 4am while the rest of japan
is grabbing a coffee on their way to
work
these surfers have been busy catching
waves okay
it's really laid back here and welcoming
it's like being in california
the shonan coastline is so close to
downtown tokyo
surfing addicts can grab a few waves on
the way to work japanese have been body
surfing for over a century
floating on small wooden planks called
itago
often decorated with ads for stores or
soap
but after world war ii when american
soldiers in japan began riding their
longboards
japanese were instantly hooked said
tokyo author
and surfer kaori shoji they looked at
the gis having fun
with just a board and they thought to
themselves hey
if they can do that so can we and that's
that's how it all started it's a place
to have fun
and relax and catch a wave or two and i
think that was
really seductive to the japanese japan's
surfing obsession supports a thriving
local beach culture
from the cafes and surf shops of
seashore mecca chigasaki
to a cottage industry of artisans sawed
a surfboard caters to a notoriously
finicky clientele
boards are fine-tuned to the surfer's
skill level body size and local wave
conditions
semi-finished polyurethane blanks are
sanded by hand
before getting a fiberglass skin and
over at deuce wetsuits
artisan hiroshi fukuzawa requires
customers to submit a checklist of
detailed body measurements
and pay nearly twice as much as
off-the-rack wetsuits
custom wetsuits were originally
handcrafted for japanese pearl divers
then artisans branched out into wetsuits
for surfers
japan's gentle waves are just right for
total newbies
i saw this perfect little wave
california transplant and now local surf
instructor gary burkhalter
showed me how to stay on my board more
or less you can surf in hawaii you can
surf in california you could surf you
know
anywhere in in bali or something but
surfing in japan is like
wow that's really special
[Music]
hot dog surfers must buy their time
waiting for
typhoons to churn up the big waves but
for the sheer
joy of watery communion japan's surf and
safari is a real day at the beach
for cbs this morning saturday lucy kraft
on the shonan coast
japan one of the few things i have not
tried that i really want to try
yeah have you both served yes in hawaii
a little bit yeah
hawaii not well i'm looking forward to
watching it in the olympics though yeah
right very cool yeah